one of the challenges I think that we
need to face head-on when we think about
how we come across to other people is
really understanding that that that
perception is tricky and that for your
perceiver the person who's trying to
understand you it's really kind of an
uphill battle they're operating on very
little information trying to get the
right accurate image of you but the good
news is that the kinds of mistakes that
perceivers make are very predictable
right it's not random we know a lot
about the kinds of signals a person
sends and how they tend to be perceived
by other people President Obama when he
was running for re-election had his
first debate with Mitt Romney and he
went into it according to everything
that was said afterwards he had gone
into it really trying to seem
presidential and not wanting to rise to
the bait you know kind of trying to take
advantage of the fact that he was coming
in as an incumbent president and it
turned out that at the end of it people
who were in the audience even people who
are fans of President Obama thought that
he had come across as lethargic as
disengaged wondering if he had had
enough sleep that night and afterwards
he was really quite surprised when he
spoke to his aides to find out how
poorly he had done because he really
thought he was very successfully coming
across as above the fray and
presidential when in fact he was
actually seeming sort of out of it and
so you can think if someone like
President Obama who's really a gifted
orator and has a lot of experience
trying to come across to other people in
a particular way if he can be so wrong
about how he's coming across then then
it's obviously pretty easy for the rest
of us to make the same mistake we tend
to think that that other people are
really paying attention really trying to
understand us when most of the time
they're happy to just get the gist of
you and the gist can be totally wrong
the first phase of perception what
Kahneman calls system 1 thinking is
really the part that's very automatic it
happens completely below your awareness
and that's where in the perceiver is
really trying to figure out you know the
basics of you are you a an anxious
person or or an honest person
or a smart person or a warm person and
we use the brain uses sort of basic
trach terms to understand you kind of
just the gist of who you are when we go
into phase 2 we take a more nuanced view
of who you are so then that's when
that's the phase where you start to do
things like take the context of
someone's behavior into account take
into account what you know of them
outside this one situation really try to
get a more nuanced view of what this
person is like now the problem is these
one is automatic it's content to just
get the gist it uses shortcuts and rules
of thumb in order to really kind of get
a sense of who you are in that thin
slice sort of way phase 2 is not
automatic it is labor intensive it
requires a lot of effort and energy to
get a more nuanced view of another
person so what happens is that much of
the time people are never going past
phase one when they're trying to
understand you they're just getting the
gist and they're either not motivated to
go into Phase two and try to really get
a more nuanced view of you or if they're
just unable to go into Phase two because
they're so busy with all the other
things we have to pay attention to so
the point of the book was really to give
people that research that science that
shows look if you want to come across as
trustworthy if you want to come across
as friendly if you want to come across
as competent or caring these are the
signals right this is the body language
these are the kinds of things you can
say in order to really clearly convey
that intent and come across the way you
intend to so it's it's definitely a
challenge coming across the way you
intend to but it's it's definitely a
challenge that with the right tools you
can master
you